we begin this morning with dangerous
weather conditions on both sides of the
country flood watches and warnings are
in effect in the Northeast while
excessive heat and high wind warnings
are up throughout the West those
conditions are feeling more than 100
wildfires in 14 states burning almost
one and a half million acres meanwhile
people from Maine to Virginia are hoping
for a dry weekend after heavy rains
saturated the northeast Friday in
Lynchburg Virginia a dam overflowed
threatening more than a hundred homes
chip Reid is in Lynchburg where things
are drying out but officials still
haven't given the all-clear chip good
morning
that's right well as you can see behind
me the level of this lake or reservoir
is way down and that is very good news
because Thursday into Friday
it was surging over this bridge and dam
and threatening to destroy the entire
structure and threatening the lives of
many people living downstream they
evacuated about 150 people and took them
to a shelter and that's where we talked
to some of them last night I saw lights
outside the window and there was a knock
on the door and the firemen were out
there saying that we were being
evacuated I am hoping that we go back
home soon but I'm a little scared to see
if there's any damage now here's the
back story three years ago engineers
studied this bridge and dam and they
concluded it probably wouldn't withstand
an extreme weather event like the one we
just had but officials couldn't decide
what to do about it
they really hemmed in hauled and debated
and now they promised that they are
going to fix this dam and bridge and
roadway and the people living downstream
are saying it's about time Dayna
hindsight is 20/20 chip Reid in
Lynchburg Virginia thanks Jim